tél
bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre la première séance
présidée par le nouveau président du
sénat le socialiste jean pierre bel
je vous le rappelle il a été élu samedi
1er octobre alors à mes côtés
j'accueille bariza khiari qui a été
réélue sénatrice socialiste de paris
dimanche 25
vous allez donc sûrement être proclamés
vice-présidente du sénat alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire pour le
téléspectateur en quoi consiste ce rôle
de vice-président est ce que c'est tout
simplement un titre honorifique
alors non ce n'est pas un titre
honorifique c'est une fonction de
travail où nous présidons nous
partageant le travail de la séance une
président laissait toutes les séances du
sénat pour faire fonctionner la maison
bien évidemment sur le plan législatif
d'abord et puis après il ya d'autres
choses qui sont liées aux fonctions de
vice président c'est des représentations
parce que le président ne veut pas aller
partout
donc il y a un rôle de représentation
évidemment alors quand jean pierre bel a
été élu e président du sénat il a dit
qu'il ne voulait pas servir un client et
qu'il tenait également à prendre en
compte les inégalités scandaleuses entre
les hommes et les femmes
alors alors est ce que la répartition
qu'il propose entre les groupes de ses
titres à savoir de ses fonctions vice
présidents questeurs et est secrétaire
du sénat
est ce qu'il le tient compte de cette
promesse dans sa répartition alors une
je dois préciser que je n'ai pas le
président du sénat qui décide pour les
gros chaque groupe décide en conscience
pour ce qui concerne le groupe
socialiste c'est la parité totale pour
les vice présidents il ya un homme une
femme et je déplore que finalement je
serai la seule femme vice-présidente du
sénat
je déplore que l'ump sur quatre os on
est nommé on n'est pas désigné on n'est
pas votée fait voter pour une femme il y
a eu et il y avait la dernière fois
madame pape en est finalement c'était la
parité contrainte ils sont revenus à
deux anciennes habitudes de
conservatisme et je le déplore vraiment
c'est pas une belle image du sénat que
de donner une image où il n'y a qu'une
seule femme qui va présider les débats
la seule femme sur les 8
huit vice président du sénat c'est bien
ça voilà c'est bien ça alors comment
concevez-vous ce rôle vice-présidente
socialiste dans un sénat à gauche c'est
une première eh bien écoutez cet
historique cette vie c'est victoire est
historique
eh bien nous allons apprendre en
marchant puisque nous avons c'est clair
c'est là une culture de minoritaires et
nous passons en quelques jours à une
culture de majoritaire donc nous allons
faire ce qu'il faut dans l'organisation
et dans la gouvernance de la maison pour
que les choses tiennent la route et vous
pouvez nous faire confiance
nous savons aussi gérés à titre
personnel comment le vivez-vous c'est un
l'aboutissement d'un long parcours
alors pour moi c'est l'aboutissement
d'un parcours formidable parce que parce
que alésia les yeux je vous en prie
c'est l'aboutissement d'un parcours
formidable parce que je mens combat et
la lutte contre les discriminations et
la visibilité de la diversité et là
franchement j'incarne ce combat de qui
est un combat de la méritocratie
républicaine la france si vous voulez le
rêve français à partir de la
méritocratie républicaine et donc moi
j'ai fait mes classes dans mon parti
comme tout le monde et je ne me
différencie pas de mes collègues
sénateurs ou de mes collègues
parlementaires dans cette maison et
aboutir avec vice-présidente du sénat
c'est pour moi un honneur et j'espère
incarner cette fonction le mieux
possible
alors reste à trancher maintenant la
question des présidences de commission à
ce que vous êtes favorable à ce qu'une
commission la commission des finances la
présidence de la commission des finances
soit à la droite
alors je dois vous dire d'abord pour les
présidences de commission que la gauche
a proposé deux présidents de commission
et puis sur la question de la
gouvernance
eh bien nous sommes en train de négocier
je pense qu'il ne s'agit pas de donner
quelque chose aux autres
il s'agit d'avoir une entente d'avoir
une entente
bon pour une gouvernance et pour bien
gouverner cette maison donc il ne s'agit
pas de donner quelque chose aux autres
il s'agit de s'entendre pour gouverner
la maison bien c'est ce que sont l
allant voir auxerre j'entends la garde
républicaine la séance va donc commencer
merci bariza khiari d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
je vous laisse regagné olé je suis très
ému merci on va suivre ça donc en direct
car nous allons prendre dans un instant
la direction de l'hémicycle pour cette
première séance je vous le disais
présidée par jean pierre bel cette
séance a pour objectif est bien de
désigner les vis mes vice présidents les
questeurs et les secrétaires du sénat ce
sont des postes clés des postes à
responsabilités qui étaient
particulièrement convoité ce qui a donné
lieu ces derniers jours à des
tractations entre les partis
voilà nous allons donc prendre la
direction de l'hémicycle pour cette
séance présidée par jean pierre bel très
bonne séance à tous
c
ce coin
oui
la séance est ouverte mes chers
collègues le procès verbal de la séance
du 1er octobre 2011 a été distribué
y at il des observations il n'y en a pas
le procès verbal est adoptée en
application de l'article 5 bis de nos
règlements
j'ai reçu les déclarations des
présidents de groupes qui souhaitent
être reconnus comme groupe minoritaire
ou groupes d'opposition au sens de
l'article 51 1 de la constitution
monsieur jean claude gaudin président du
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
m'a fait connaître que son groupe se
déclare comme groupes d'opposition
monsieur jacques mézard président du
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen et monsieur françois
zocchetto président du groupe de l'union
centriste et républicaine ont quant à
eux informés que leur groupe se déclare
comme groupes minoritaires
chacun de ces groupes pourra donc au
cours de la session bénéficier des
droits attribués au groupe d'opposition
et y minoritaires par la constitution et
notre règlement notamment dans le cadre
des journées mensuel réservés l'ordre du
jour appelle la désignation des vice
présidents questeurs et secrétaire du
sénat et la proclamation de la
constitution du bureau définitif
conformément à l'article 3 du règlement
la liste des candidats à chacune de ses
fonctions a été affichée à 12h30
cette liste n'a fait l'objet d'aucune
opposition pendant le vice président
si didier guillaume monsieur jean pierre
raffarin
madame bariza khiari monsieur thierry
foucaud monsieur jean léonce dupont
monsieur jean patrick courtois monsieur
charles guené monsieur jean claude carle
aux fonctions de questeur monsieur jean
marc todeschini monsieur gérard dériot
monsieur allen en diani
pour ce qui concerne les secrétaires du
sénat monsieur jean boyer monsieur marc
daunis madame michelle demessine des
messies d'un pardon madame marie-hélène
des esgaulx monsieur jean desessard
monsieur alain dufaut monsieur hubert
falco
monsieur françois fortassin monsieur
jacques gillot madame odette herviaux
monsieur jean françois humbert monsieur
gérard le cam madame marie noelle
linemann madame catherine procast ya je
déclare le bureau constitué
communication en sera donnée à monsieur
le président de la république et à
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
nationale
je vais suspendant la séance elle sera
reprise à 19h30 pour la nomination des
membres des six commissions permanentes
et de la commission spéciale chargée du
contrôle des comptes et de l'évaluation
interne
la séance est suspendue voilà vous venez
de suivre cette première séance très
courte puisqu'il s'agissait
et bien tout simplement pour le
président jean pierre bel de proclamer
en séance publique les membres qui vont
constituer le bureau du sénat à mes
côtés jean pierre chevènement sénateur
du groupe rds du territoire de belfort
bonjour bonjour alors c'est aujourd'hui
que se joue finalement la répartition
des postes à responsabilités au sénat
est ce que vous allez avoir un de ces
postes
alors on a vu pas de vice-présidence
pour vous mais peut-être un poste de
président de commission s'est elle
engagements qui avaient été pris à mon
égard avant l'élection du président jean
pierre bel comme vous le savez la
majorité de gauche et diverses
comporte plusieurs composantes dont le
rdse qui est lui-même divers donc
j'observe que ce qui était vrai la
semaine dernière ne l'est plus
aujourd'hui
le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense qui a
été désigné par le groupe socialiste et
monsieur jean louis carrère donc voilà
ce qui était vrai hier ne l'est plus
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on va pas scinder cette
commission de justement d'un côté
affaires étrangères et de l'autre la
défense et la présence pour mieux
revenir
oui c'est ce qu'on dit mais j'ai
l'habitude les promesses non tenues je
pourrais vous en fournir un abondant
catalogue
il semblait particulièrement amer
aujourd'hui monsieur chevènement au où
je ne suis pas amer je regarde comment
les choses se passent et je sais que ce
qui était vrai hier ne l'est pas
aujourd'hui un erreur en deçà des
pyrénées un vérité au delà
est ce que ça veut dire que ça va
remettre en cause peut-être votre
soutien à jean pierre bel écoutez on
verra je reste un homme de gauche
indépendant libre de mes votes de mai
détermination est-ce que vous pensez que
le groupe r d ce finalement être un peu
oublié de dans l'attribution de tous ces
postes particulièrement convoités au
sénat certainement puisque je vois que
même les verts qui n'ont que dix
sénateurs ont hérité de la présidence
d'une commission qui existent alors que
nous nous n'avons mérité que de vagues
promesses
justement le groupe des verts à peine
arrivés ils obtiennent un groupe une
commission une peut-être bien une
présidence de commission
comment ont-ils réussi ce tour de force
celle en vous c'est la mode savez c'est
la mode la mode à laquelle vous
contribuez d'ailleurs un disons que les
républicains de gauche n'ont pas cette
chance
écoutez merci jean pierre chevènement
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur
public sénat je vais maintenant demander
je pense à philippe marini monsieur
marini si vous le voulez bien vous êtes
sur public sénat venait à mes côtés
philippe marini alors la question qui
reste en suspens aujourd'hui bien c'est
cette présidence de la commission des
finances est ce qu'elle vous est acquise
rendez vous demain matin à 9h30 est ce
que ça veut dire les tractations sont
toujours en cours il n'y a pas de
tractations
il a été dit par le président du sénat
que cette fonction
dans le cadre d'une gouvernance partagée
avait vocation à être exercé par l'ump
par un représentant du groupe ump
j'ai été désigné hier à l'unanimité par
le groupe ump pour être son candidat à
la présidence de la commission
donc voilà c'est très simple et il
suffit d'attendre demain 9h30
on a bien entendu un bang message on va
attendre demain 9h30
a priori ce serait un nicole bricq qui
serait rapporteur général du budget
comment vous envoyer visage et le
travail bien finalement avec un
rapporteur de gauche et un président de
droite à la commission des finances
nous avons l'habitude de travailler
ensemble il y à une estime réciproque
même si nous n'avons naturellement pas
les mêmes positions sur beaucoup de
sujets ça n'empêche pas de travailler
ensemble dans le cadre d'une gouvernance
partagée
il y aura des rapporteurs de la majorité
des rapporteurs de l'opposition un
rapporteur général qui prendra en charge
totalement sa mission et qui sera le
vrai leader politique de la commission
c'est à dire émanant de la majorité de
la commission mais sans oublier que
c'est une majorité de 25 contre 24
alors ça promet justement des séances
est particulièrement animé l'actuel
enfin l'ancien président de la
commission des finances il est toujours
jusqu'à demain alors je me reprends donc
l'actuel président de la commission des
finances le centriste jean arthuis
également candidat si la commission des
finances vous revient finalement les
centristes un peu les grands perdants de
la répartition de tous ces postes à
responsabilités du sénat ils ont été les
grands gagnants pendant de nombreuses
années
la roue tourne ses côtés s'il y a
accor c'est un accord entre les deux
groupes les plus importants du sénat les
deux principaux groupes d'un côté de la
majorité et de l'autre de l'opposition
et sincèrement là la solution la plus
simple vous savez pour modifier les
termes de ce problème
et bien c'est d'adhérer au groupe ump
très bien merci
philippe marini d'avoir répondu à nos
questions donc nous vous suivrons bien
entendu et bien le la prochaine étape
donc pour savoir qui préside la
commission des finances du sénat
c'est la fin de cette séance merci à
tous d'avoir suivi très belle fin de
journée à tous sur public sénat ne
manquez pas ce soir à partir de 20
heures le dernier débat le débat décisif
entre les candidats à la primaire
socialiste
à très bientôt sur public sénat